politics is not my business and i'm not
a politician well fast forward to 2020
and dwayne johnson is making
politics his business i do feel that
vice president biden and senator harris
are the best choice to lead our country
and i am endorsing them to become
president and vice president
of our united states on sunday the rock
through his support behind democratic
nominee joe biden
and his running mate senator kamala
harris in his first ever public
presidential endorsement
you know look i've got friends in all
parties but the one thing that we can
always agree on is the conversation and
the dialogue and where that conversation
lands
is always the most critical part now
this is something that i've certainly
not done in the past
so i'm gonna go big and he sure did the
actor virtually sat down with biden and
harris which also marked his first time
meeting the senator
i'm a huge fan of everything from fast
and furious all of them to jumanji
so thank you for your work in the seven
and a half minute long video
the former wrestler praised biden for
his compassion and heart and drive
but also soul and called harris a
certified badass
johnson also asked hard-hitting
questions like this one
how will the both of you earn the
respect
of all the american people once you're
in that white house
by doing what we say we're going to do
by keeping our word
by leveling with the american people by
taking responsibility
when we fail acknowledge it the senator
went on to speak about the importance of
truth
following the coronavirus pandemic and
its effects
truth can sometimes be really difficult
to hear
and for that reason sometimes people
don't speak it people are grieving
i mean people are grieving the loss of
life the loss of
jobs the loss of certainty the loss of
normalcy
and to heal and get through this we're
going to have to be
honest about what healing will require
harris tweeted the video of their
conversation
welcoming johnson to team joe and biden
thanked the rock for his support
and joked that next time we're talking
cars
is there going to be a president johnson
i think anything's possible
right this is america in the past the
rock flirted with the idea of the
presidential run himself
we had had these conversations in the
past you and i have talked about it in
the past
it's kind of been like throw away we
make a funny joke about it but what has
been so flattering over the past
week and really really humbling and very
eye opening is the amount of american
people who actually want to see this
happen yeah and it really means so much
to me and i do a pretty good job
in terms of leadership and in terms of
galvanizing a lot of people and bringing
them together
to get a job done and to be better but
that's what a president does
that is it's one of the qualities yes of
the president
so can we see a president dwayne johnson
in our future
here's what he said i just got to
continue to do what i do again i'm not a
politician i still like putting in the
work of my own two hands and sweating
every day and we'll see